[Music]  welcome to the secret headquarters of  the SES stands for small foot exist  suckas we have searched the entire  mountain and that day has finally  arrived calm down you know it can't be  true legal you will be banished from the  village until you are ready to tell us  that she too late to have second  thoughts if you die can I have all your  worldly possessions right sorry when you  die let's do this  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  either the first it's the high  [Music]  I'm taking you home  [Music]  me  [Music]  we're gonna be safe here nice and warm  oh wait a minute what's how's that nice  and toasty all the way around hey what's  wrong  you hungry I found your food  [Music]